hi everyone welcome welcome to north
east derbyshire district council
this is our question and our answer
session on zoom
you'll see that i'm using british sign
language
for the benefit of the deaf community
living in north east derbyshire
we have a number of people on the call
but i'll introduce myself first my name
is robin ash and i work for the british
deaf association
and we also have a sign language
interpreter here called carly
but we have three extra people and
they're going to introduce themselves
they'll give you their name their job
role and the organisational company that
they work for so aymar can we start with
you
yes thank you so my name is aymar bashir
i work for northeast dobson district
council and i look after a quality
performance so apart my role includes
delivering training engaging with the
different communities of northeast
derbyshire and writing policies and
procedures to assist the organization
thank you
thank you
donna
hello there so i'm donna cowley
a customer services team leader
i work within the team that delivers all
the council's frontline service requests
at the first point of contact wherever
possible
this is across all access channels
whether it's face-to-face email text
telephone
94 of our inquiries that come into the
customer services are dealt with by our
team at the first point of contact
one of my duties is to quality monitor
the team to ensure we continue to
deliver quality services to all our
residents
thank you
passing over to claire
hi i'm claire vale um i'm managing
director of sign solutions and we
provide the interpreters live service
for north east derbyshire council which
is a video relay service which will come
on to what that is later
we are a national organization so we
provide not just video interpreting but
face to face-to-face interpretation
translations and deaf awareness training
and also employment support across the
uk
and we're available 24 7.
thank you everyone for joining the q a
session today
we have a list of questions for you
and first of all i would like to ask
donna
for the benefit of the deaf community
what does customer service actually mean
um
customer service to myself and our team
is about going the extra mile really
exceeding the customers expectations
um treating somebody as you'd like to be
treated yourself
being as informative as you can be
um respectful
um being non-judgmental
um and if we here at uh northeast don't
have the answer um then we can signpost
uh that resident to someone or the
service
that they need
thank you for the explanation so that's
a bit clearer now we know what customer
service is i was just wondering that if
a deaf person wants to make contact with
north east derbyshire
district council
yeah through vrs i mean how do they do
that um vrs they can do that on a link
on on our website
um this connects them to a video
interpreter
and then they make the onward telephone
call
through to us here in the customer
service center
okay that's
a new service that's really interesting
i was wondering that um i mean
i'm not sure that deaf people really
understand what vrs means so i don't
know whether claire could you give us a
bit more of an explanation about what
that actually means yeah of course
so obviously any organization that has a
phone number
um really should be accessible to the
deaf community
and enable them to communicate with that
organization in british sign language
their first or preferred language so
that's what vrs does and donna explained
it really well
and basically they can they can have a
video call with a an on-demand
interpreter
who is nrcpd registered qualified
interpreter
they are based all around the uk
and they can initiate that call via the
website choosing to click on a link and
come through to the interpreter or they
can download an app if they're using an
apple device and they come through to
the interpreter who then makes the
onward telephony call
to um customer services team and once
that call is connected to the council if
customer services were signposting it to
another department within the council
that can just transfer the call in the
same way as any other telephone call
that comes in
okay
i think this is some
quite new to the north east derbyshire
deaf community
and i was wondering
that deaf people quite often ask me
about vrs and whether they can have
their local interpreter
and they also ask about qualifications
and registration so could you clarify
sort of how that works
yeah for me to answer yeah um so
with um video relay service it's an
on-demand service so we have
interpreters that are based regionally
across the uk so they could end up
coming through to any of those regional
interpreters however if they were coming
in for an appointment or they wanted to
specifically request a certain
interpreter that they are familiar with
for a call
we can pre-book that interpreter that
they request to make that call for them
or have that have be online on the ipad
for when they come in for the meeting
but that would have to be pre-booked to
make sure that that interpreter is
available
and that can be within the application
that the council have access to or
if the council want to use a different
video solution we can bring the
interpreter into any video platform
it's good for the deaf community to know
that they have some choice still
because um
deaf people quite often like to know who
they're going to be
working with and who they have to
interpret for them so that's useful
information to know
the other thing that the deaf community
are often asking me
is um well why do i need to contact the
council what would i want to what would
i want to make
a call to the council via an interpreter
for so i wondered if i could ask the
council
um or maybe donna you could give some
examples of why people may need to make
contact with the council in the first
place
okay yeah
um well basically we'll we'll help with
anything we can really um
obviously we do have our you know
purposes while we're here um so for us
here um at the district council we deal
with things like benefits council tax
business rates
environmental health issues
concessionary travel passes
um homeless housing advice
anti-social behavior
um but then we we also get calls from
residents you know requiring help
elsewhere
um
we we sometimes get calls about in
restaurants and opening times and things
um even though you know it's not
under the council we'll we'll always try
and help where we can and we'll find
that information for that resident
that's useful to know too i mean deaf
people
have been saying why would i want to
contact the council so you've given us
quite a good list there
and there's a derbyshire county council
they deal with
other other issues um a few examples of
those would be things like highways
so potholes
access things like street lighting
education um adult social care
etc so there is a difference but if they
come through to us you know
we deal with it all the time and we will
signpost them through
thank you for adding that that bit of
information because that clarifies
some important issues for some people
too
now the deaf community
will be telling them that they can use
vrs to make contact
but how do
deaf people find the link if we say to
them you can use it they need to know
specific information about how where to
find it
either of you could answer that i don't
know who who feels they want to answer
that one
it should be if you go north east
armstrong district council you go on to
our our website there in it and it
should be there
right at the bottom of the screen
and it should and it will say contact us
and there's also um a british sign
language um button as well at the bottom
of the screen
um and i think
when we do share some of the videos um
around how to find the website and how
to contact um that will be helpful um
also kobe has prevented a lot of the
normal awareness events that the council
or ourselves would do so there's some of
those going to be planned um to be able
to create a little bit more awareness
and also for people to have a go and
then understand the technology a little
bit it's so easy to use
and so simple um just literally a click
and you can come through to an
interpreter
and the other way you can find the
council is um via our website so we have
a directory of all the organizations in
the uk you can contact and they're in
sectors so all the councils are together
all the nhs organizations are together
so you can click on that button and go
straight to um derbyshire's north east
irish's page
oh that's useless well i don't know
who's that
amar did you want to say
yes um again just to repeat what donna
and claire said that it is available on
the front page and through the science
solutions website and we should be able
to have a link at the bottom of this
video as well with the description so if
you want to save that in your favorites
and your internet explorer or whichever
browser you use then it'll just make the
process a little bit quicker for you
brilliant great explanation for the deaf
community on how how to actually get the
interpreter to pop up on the screen
now a lot of deaf people
often ask me
that
about their circumstances because they
don't have a mobile phone
or they don't have
the technology so
how do those
deaf people make contact with account
with the council to to get services can
anybody help with that question
um yeah i mean we've got some um email
they can use email um obviously they
need access to a computer um if they
don't have that there are libraries
where they can access that service
we do have a text facility as well
so you should be able to text like from
even if it's not a smartphone
um
obviously there's the vrs and then we
you know face to face um if they feel
you know confident in in coming down to
see us um
you know we we are very approachable
down here um and we'll you know we'll do
our best to help where we can
and that's good information for us to
pass to the deaf community because
if they're lacking in confidence in one
area whether it's technology or face to
face they've got other options yeah
and it's also really important that deaf
people
have some hints and tips about
you know what to say when they call
rather than just to click on that link
and not be clear about what information
they need so
um is there anything they need to know
specifically about the technology about
the quality of camera or the background
or is there anything that would be
really useful for them to know in terms
of the technology well i answer that so
and when they um click when they land on
the website and they click on the link
to call without downloading the app and
they'll be immediately taken to a page
where they can test um
their camera so it will show them what
they look like they can check that their
hands are in view because obviously
that's how we're going to be
communicating um and they can check that
their camera is working before they
actually press the call now button when
they do press the call now button and
they come through to an interpreter the
interpreter will also check that they
understand each other that they can see
each other before they make the
connection um via audio and phone onto
the council
and it's the same from the app
perspective as well they will see a
screen first a bit like when you join a
zoom call or a team score you can check
all your settings before you actually
make a call
um and then when they do come through to
us if they ask for
a department that isn't in the directory
or you know they're not going through
domain switchboard something like that
they can give us the phone number and we
can type that in um
so we should be able to connect them
really um swiftly to the character but
they will always check those that they
can see each other and that they've got
a camera and it's working before they
make the call
useful tips but very important tips
thank you for that
i have one more question
the councils and companies are using
uh vrs already and i'm i'm curious to
know about
feedback from the deaf community i mean
i'm sure that you want to know how the
deaf community feel
when they've used the service so they
can give you an idea of what their
experience was like because i think
feedback is really important so how
would they give that feedback
so right so if if someone's used our
service we have on our contact us page
they can send us a bsl video they can
call us via video to give feedback
they can text
live chat
email
so those are the options and also we'll
be releasing our app soon um which is
still powered by the same system but it
will give them a feedback button option
on there as well and we also have a
feedback page where they can select
a slider scale as to their score out of
10 and they can add as much or as little
feedback as they wish
and also every call that we have
we know which interpreters are on shift
at which time and the calls they've
taken so we can always investigate a
call if if there was an issue raised
can i answer that
yes go ahead
okay i'm just gonna say um
we do have um a comments uh compliments
and complaints system uh where residents
can access um on our website
um
so they can give us feedback on there
also by email or text
and we also
send out like satisfaction surveys as
well um and it
you know we are interested in um how
they find the service so that you know
we can improve it
um so it's really useful to have that
brilliant thank you everyone
this has been really useful information
for the deaf community
because often
uh deaf people say oh why bother people
don't you know people not interested in
our feedback but you you genuinely are
and i think it's really important that
they know that that's the only way that
services can be improved if people
tell
you how they feel about the system so
we'll be encouraging the communities of
the northeast derbyshire to to do that
and thank you for being here thank you
for answering my questions it's really
appreciated
and if deaf people have
any more questions
uh perhaps they could ring the council
via vrs and ask questions
um i'm sure that customer service will
be happy to hear from them
yes if they need any more information
about the
you know the system how it works
um
i don't know if there's anything that
you you feel you need to add to anything
that i've said
um not really robin's covered it very
very well and i think that the rest of
the
the attendees have as well we'll be
providing all the information attached
to the description of this video as well
so in terms of the landing page in terms
of how to give feedback and we the
council we do believe in continuous
improvement as well so it is a cycle
where we see an improvement we make the
improvement and then we get feedback to
make sure that it is you know helping
the communities as well so we're always
open and i think we've done a lot of
work already with robin with the bsl
charter this is one of the actions from
that charter as well i think remember we
had a launch with the charter as well
and this is the next stage so so we are
working towards the action plan and we
are making progress with the community
and hopefully we'll be able to attend
forums once covert is over and
everything is hopefully back to normal
and i would just add um obviously the
the plan is to set up some more
awareness events and deaf community
events and also to um
to share videos on how to access the
service so make sure you follow our
social media and also the council so
that you can keep up to date with those
announcements
brilliant yes thank you
amar for um
facilitating the meeting thank you to
northeast derbyshire
council
thank you for trying to improve access
for the deaf community and
providing the vrs
as a service through the council because
that gives deaf people equality and
access
so
thank you um donna from customer service
thank you claire
thank you everybody for answering the
questions and hopefully we will make
progress with this
and you know it's been really useful to
hear from claire at science solutions
about how this system works and finally
thank you to the interpreter as well for
signing and voicing throughout
so we will have more information to
update the deaf community in the future
take care of yourselves and bye for now